how can this be good hello everybody and
welcome to Tao I feel oh god I don't
think I feel good anymore Oh what have I
done my computer can't handle this bring
it on serve these jerks would just stay
out of my way I'm fine
Oh bring me the noise all still in it
oh god damn it oh come on baby
Oh so elegant like a butterfly try this
once more you know what I mean oh if I
can just make it past that train I'll be
fine it's proving to be more difficult
than I rejoice Wow bring
Oh Mitch I got this oh god I do not got
this death come on baby baby baby baby
come on baby come on baby come on
[Music]
why I'd love to know how I can survive
this oh I can't that's right what a
beautiful relaxing day what happened
what a for us is now feel the Noize kind
of feel the burn feel the speed feel the
power
now that is a nice donkey got there oh
[ __ ] oh please stop just gonna sit and
relax here for a little bit while I
contemplate my life everything avoids me
apparently these hips that it is my face
with my face go I'm the most beautiful
butterfly battery bag
[Music]
[Applause]
oh you bring it on harder than you've
ever brought it on before because I'm
ready I'm ready for it
apparently I'm not ready by oh yeah oh
no oh god no back world's greatest nut
shot that hurt me hey let's see what
happened today
oh by truck oh yes oh no slow and steady
wins the race
oh this is just insanity why Superman
wow this isn't gonna end well Oh God
body truck I take that back
how can this be bad it's like the
perfect impact every single time what
happens when I go slow that donkey ain't
gonna be wrong what if this was real and
some idiot on a chicken car came honk
honk
watch out from a donk so cool yeah it's
so good ok cuz there goes my head slow
and steady wins the race
slow and steady also kills my face
the loss of junk alright I'm all out of
time because this been insane almost all
these are workshop levels that people
have been making all around the world so
if you got a crazy idea that you want me
to play make it I will play it so anyway
thanks everybody for watching leave a
like if you enjoyed the video and as
always I will see you
[Music]